Republicans have elected Rock ribbed
conservative Mike Johnson I mean that
sincerely ordinarily I would say that is
a joke whenever Republicans elect a
leader but they actually they picked a
conservative guy Johnson has a lifetime
rating of 92% from the American
conservative Union and a 90% rating from
Heritage action quite good he's got an
A+ rating from Susan banthony pro-life
America he authored legislation last
year to Outlaw the libs weird sexual
indoctrination of kids and unlike the
previous GOP nominee for speaker he
voted to defend the real definition of
marriage as late as last December when
Joe Biden the Democrats and the squish
Republicans tried successfully I'm sorry
to say to codify the oberfell same-sex
marriage decision into law